Uh, dreaming,
dreaming.
We brought together eight professional models. I am a model.
I'm a model. I'm a model. I am a professional fashion.
Model. I am a professional model.
I'm a professional model.
I'm a model. One is a liar.
If the group discovers who the liar is, they'll win a cash prize.
If the liar survives, they win the cash prize.
Odd man out.
My current game plan is to kind of see people that might get confused by certain
terms that average people.
Just wouldn't know.
Show themselves pretty easily. Everything behind you about being a model.
It's not just posing. Okay.
Some things you might think you know from the outside,
but then once you actually work as a model, it's all very different.
It could be the more Molly Rams with them. All the twins look moly.
It's for Melissa and I and all of these it's home.
I am America's next top model.
Hi everyone.
So I'm asking where, where is everybody based in Toronto?
I'm based in Orlando. Orlando is like,
I don't know about that,
but I'm not sure I'm from the Netherlands.
What is the number one thing you never want to wear?
How did you guys
get scouted signed?
I got scouted
working freedoms. Should I say that though?
My friend got me into modeling. Hmm. Okay.
That's got it from a college fashion show.
I'm in D pendant. I am not signed,
but book a lot. So.
You do everything yourself or another Instagram or?
Oh, it's a lot of Instagram. Instagram not signed,
but George books, everything by himself this year. That's so sad.
I got scouted from Instagram. Okay. Yolanda. Absolutely not. You are the mole.
So yours is George George. And say how to, no, I don't want to target.
You don't want to target here, right?
All over in New York, but he's from the East coast. What do you mean?
We're in New York. All right.
I want to know what do you never
show up to eight shoot. Molly.
What do you never.
Show too? She didn't. Why is she asking the same question over and over?
What's your favorite type of monument?
Genesis says I'm independent, but I've been signed previously.
Oh, 10, nine, eight. No, no Prince lifestyle. No.
One's going to answer my position. It's tight. Ooh. Ooh.
This is stressful. My heart is beating.
I don't want to vote anybody out on chat. I'm scared. What if they vote we way?
Because they think I like no too much.
George said he books, everything himself.
He probably doesn't know how scouting works and stuff like that.
I'm definitely voting for Yolanda. Just because of her Instagram comment.
She said she got scouted from Instagram,
which is definitely a thing.
I wasn't got it through Instagram. Yeah.
I'm voting out George this round because he mentioned something about how agents
should get you gigs. Yes. Unless you're not signed like myself.
He sounds very researched.
I think I'm going to vote for
Yolanda said she was based in Orlando. I don't know anybody.
Who's based in Orlando and it's working professionally. It's very bad.
That doesn't mean she's not a model. It's definitely Molly or George, I think.
Oh, you want George? Okay. I'm okay. If anything, George,
George is not sorry. That's okay, Molly. We're doing Molly.
What are you looking at? I swear if I get bored.
Round one, Melissa is going to lose it.
The first person voted out is.
George.
The reason why I feel like I got voted off was because I said I was independent.
Now being independent, especially in this day and age is kind of a good thing.
One, your agency doesn't take 10 to 20% of your check.
You get all of that lends itself into honey. If you want to become successful,
you find the work yourself, honestly,
kind of iconic to get eliminated first because you're too pretty.
Or because you like are killing it already.
The prize challenge. Okay.
10 Minutes to take a photo of yourself. Choose your backdrop,
your lighting, work your angles. How you please, if you want to edit it.
Work your angles. This is going to be fun. Ready? Set. Go.
Where.
We're going to set up the prompts here. Set it up.
That takes away all the iPads until I kind of reflect under your face.
Are you sure of the plants? Yeah. Yeah. Just go on. Go on together. Hold on,
hold on. Hold on. Don't laugh.
Outside. It's cloudy. That's such good lighting. Okay.
It's raining outside or not trying to get struck by lightning. Okay.
We're going inside. Inside. Who? Doesn't love a good.
Set with an animal who I guess, Oh no. Wait, go.
Find a good area to take the selfie. And this would look good
in Priscilla.
Quickly, quickly edit the light really quickly.
And the high contrast high contrast. Yes. Touch the skin. Touch all the skin.
Go, go, go, go.
Go Showtime. I like those words.
Oh, she looks great. I think I did.
Okay with that challenge. I think I got my ankles. Oh my goodness.
She's a model.
Oh wow. Oh wow.
That's me and my baby. Her.
Hair is huge and beautiful.
Um, I always,
when Darlene.
[Inaudible] let's give me move me.
Uh, please.
I bet.
She's really looking into that camera with those eyes.
She got the props to, I attend no problem. My only problem with this wig girl.
Oh, Hey on.
Don't tell Yolanda she's so gorgeous. So pretty the pose. Okay. Yeah.
I think she's a model. I was trying to go outside and it started to rain.
But it's about the same poses. They like,
let me look at Genesis and look at like everyone did
this. I mean, nothing's, it's a nice pose.
I mean it does between you and a lot of stuff.
It's not cold enough. It's too hot. It's not just my sweater anymore.
Josh. [inaudible] Josh.
Very pretty face. Pretty hard eyes. His skin is like glowy.
Oh wow.
This is a lot. You're real cute fellow. But you're not a model.
Certainly your angles. Joshua.
Certainly. No, your ankles. Joshua. Why should call him Joshua?
His name is Joshua here. What would you do if you says, wait.
Oh, what's y'all doing,
I didn't expect it to look like that. They definitely.
I don't even know how to respond to that. Wow.
Wow. So photogenic. Wow. This is terrible.
We're not worried. We're not worthy. We're not worthy.
Hire them. Hire them right now.
Oh, like two suspects, Convenia. And I'm still on you Josh.
I'm sorry, Josh. She beautiful. He took it like out on his front porch.
I could be totally wrong. Look at me. I look like.
A clown. They took it for my streamline high angle.
You're given 10 minutes. I don't expect an overhead selfie.
Canadia. She had more of a goofy picture. It was funny,
but like the angles look kind of odd and off to me.
Gosh, I'm a little suspicious of a brand name on his chest.
And that's usually as a model. It's a big no-no.
I'm going to go from Molly. You killed it. I wasn't feeling those like model,
model buyers. You know what I'm saying?
I probably have the most basic selfie out of all of them. So we're going to see.
The next person eliminated is,
uh, she really cute.
She hitting on Josh.
Honestly. I don't even feel bad about it.
Everybody in this entire chat looks amazing and they
kill it at Molly better than I ever, ever.
Hey guys,
now it's really starting.
Can you guys hear the clown on the left and we can hear you. Good.
Hear you. Okay, cool. Yeah. So I guess we should start asking questions.
What are your rates?
Um, or we have an agency fee. It depends on the game. You know,
how long is the media campaign? How long does it go and buy in?
It depends if the agency booked me my job or if I booked it myself and it
definitely depends. Is it half a day? Is it like an e-com day of 12,
10 or 12 hours? It's going to.
For me it differs too.
Just cause like I'm also dance talent and stuff like that.
Sometimes they need like background dancers.
Sometimes it's just like a short film.
I usually get all the details first and then I'll send them like a quote.
And then also like sometimes I'll have a flat rate.
Now when I'm working with the big names, then I'll get paid.
But I usually just do, uh, art trades for now.
You guys own models or do also things outside of modeling, no model job.
Me personally is not sustainable. You have a part-time job.
So you're working two jobs to I'm sure that if you want to go to the next game,
you have to get someone to cover for your shift.
Motto. I'm a painter, I'm a performance artist and I am way too much
here. It is just the right amount since I also work at planet smoothie.
So if you guys ever need a smoothie, I'm an artist. I do singing.
I play guitar. I play piano singing.
So I model a sing dance teach act basically like everything,
performing arts. Um, and then I also paint. So I love doing that.
And I do makeup as well.
I'm a model and actor and I do styling too.
I'm a model. Believe me, is this convincing it?
Um, they all seem so genuine,
but I am going to kind of go towards Molly.
Maybe she just seems like old, too much.
It sounded like she was maybe more into art and production.
I think Molly's definitely knows her stuff. I think it's gender system.
Not a rate question. It doesn't matter what rate you get it,
but it depends on the budget. You have to ask the company or campaign.
So ask the person to be raised. Very influenced your life.
Okay. I'm going to vote for Molly on sorry. Draw that gamer headset.
And then also she was trying really hard to convince us though.
Rhonda, any of my cancels of winning by I think it's leg
because she has led today. That's great. But that picture,
I hope they remember before this building.
I am with child.
So the next person eliminated for round three
is folly.
Okay. It was Molly. Molly got eliminated.
Real.
I'm done. I'm done killing me.
[inaudible].
For everyone. How do you guys prepare for a shoot?
You're mentally as far as like how I would dress,
like for a shoe and stuff like that, just something really comfortable.
Cause I know I'm going to be waiting all day. I bring like a magazine, no oils,
no like sensitive stuff. I want to get on the clothing mentally. I meditate,
pray before and I listen to good music and you know, what about y'all?
I definitely always have like three pairs of fluffy socks, like in my bag.
Cause like, sometimes like it's so cold,
but usually like a week before I kind of just like distress.
So for me that means like dancing or like doing something that I really love
eating like really clean drinking,
nothing but water trying not to like blow or anything like that.
For me, it's pretty similar.
I also just try to be in a good mood because being social with like a stylist or
being social with the makeup artists helps me as well.
I always like shave and my hair. That's like the biggest deal.
So if I know I have a shoot the day after tomorrow,
I'm going to like wash my hair to two days before.
And then the second day I'm always tries it for us. I mean,
we prepare a lot too. I mean, for the whole beak,
the minute you have like that kind of, you know, like just something messed you,
just like why like a pimple, you have to like study the mood boards so much.
And we do like face mask before like the narrow issue.
Yeah.
This round. Um, what's a lot harder. I'm not really suspicious of anyone,
but I'm going to have to go with, um, Genesis.
I feel like I trust the twins the most they're so photogenic,
even in the zoom call, like they look so good.
Oh my God. It's just nerve wracking to know that someone could do them all.
I think we still agree with Genesis.
She asked the question like physically or mentally. It's like, well
[inaudible], it's not a good reasoning, but so maybe she's more of a tensor.
I Genesis.
Like her lighting is perfect. Um, maybe not talking about it,
maybe she's a makeup artist. I feel like the target might be on me.
So I'm going to try to throw my boat at Yolanda.
The results of round four are tie.
The tie is between Yolanda and Genesis.
The ties between.
Then do next resolve that tie is we're going to have a
32nd pose off.
Okay. Yeah, this is all I caught. I call it, I call it.
Okay. Yeah.
Yeah. Wow.
She knows it. She knows it. And she Oh
yes. Oh yes.
Wow. Okay. Oh yeah.
She's a model. Oh my goodness. Ooh,
fantastic. You can tell that the side profile.
There's a thing. Give us a second.
Yeah.
So we did a revolt after our wonderful ladies were willing to do a pose off.
Uh, we are hide again.
We're at another tie. Oh my gosh, guys, tired again.
You have two options. We can end the game here.
If you give me a thumbs down or we can go into another round with
everyone. If you give me a thumbs up, but again, majority rules.
I want to end the game. I think they're all good.
Everybody here is a model.
I think we got them all out.
I think it's believable at this point. They're scared.
All right. We have a unanimous vote down. So we're stopping the game.
So if the color is green,
our remaining players won. If the color is red,
our remaining players lost. Ready. Three,
two, one.
It was probably Quincy and Willie.
Who was it that I really think you were right? I think we were right.
Who did this to me?
I want to talk to you. I'm now I'm upset.
I'm going to ask them all to raise their hand.
[inaudible] I'm highly offended. So that's all I have. I'm so sorry, Molly.
Okay. I'm so sorry. I like, I hate lying to people. This is hard.
I tried to sign to like a modeling agency,
but they turned out to be like a scam and stuff.
So I just never tried after that.
All of my knowledge is actually all from my friend. Shauni she's a great model.
I love her. But yeah, none of that is mine whatsoever.
You got us girl. The first person I voted for was Yolanda.
So therefore who really won here, the first person out.
Now we can end it.
Well, you'd go.
A professional model to me is someone who works hard like,
Oh my goodness model is just always changing,
evolving in so many different types of modeling. As long as.
You know how to work, your angles and audience.
Um, character.
Isn't afraid to take chances.
You would have to have a certain look or a certain size to be signed.
You don't have to be working day.
Day. I guess. You know, my posting is good enough.
So if anybody wants to hire me, come at me, baby,
I'm ready. I learned to trust them
Except that you can trust her.
I gave you silence retired.
I told you
[inaudible].